I hopefully you all have been able to
see Godzilla hopefully you're one of the
ones who contributed to Godzilla making
a [ __ ] Tilian dollars as last weekend
and what has become kind of a tradition
that's not actually a tradition cuz I
won't do this with every movie but it's
kind of a tradition I'm gonna do a
spoiler video for Godzilla as an
official spoiler warning if you're one
of the people who watched million dollar
arm this last weekend well go ahead and
stick around for this video to figure
out why you should have seen this
instead so Godzilla starts out with
Bryan Cranston Bryan Cranston is killing
it because he's Bryan Cranston he's like
I don't need to do anything else in the
world but I will because acting is fun
and he gives the most emotional moment
in the entire movie in the first 10-15
minutes of the movie he works at this
nuclear plant this nuclear reactors
melting down his wife is down there
because he sent her down there and this
thing is just melting down and she's
running and he's like I gotta make the
tough call of these seals is door before
she can escape and she dies right in
front of him do you remember Star Trek
The Next Generation when counselor Troi
was going up for our promotion and she
was doing that simulator and ultimately
she would get the promotion when she
learned she had to send someone to die
of radiation that took her an hour to
learn that [ __ ] Bryan Cranston has to do
it in the first 10 to 15 minutes of this
movie and it's his wife yeah that's
rough [ __ ] so after that Bryan
Cranston's going crazy but he's not
actually crazy because he's right he's
like they're hiding something but sure
enough they are hiding something I was
like alright they're hiding Godzilla
Godzilla's gonna do the thing hatches
and I'm like that's not Godzilla that's
that weird bat arm thing we saw in the
trailer right there out the gate I was
like cool this movie is already throwing
the unexpected at me because I didn't
think that would be the actual monster
that's terrorizing the world that was
gonna be Godzilla but you find out
Godzilla's the great equalizer
Tim Bryan Cranston dies and I was like
wait we're already attached to this guy
his wife died we saw him cried he was
right about everything he's dead so now
we get this really statuesque army guy
that we're now gonna bond with but we're
not really gonna bond with because he
seems emotionally distant but you know
you still empathize with him because
he's you know your common guy not as
good as Bryan Cranston no but the point
is this this monster was really cool
because it would send out EMP pulses I
was like that's awesome they're from
this prehistoric time which you know
that would make sense to have EMP pulses
in prehistoric times because of all
those electronics that dinosaurs are
using so this thing is tromping through
looking for radiation to feed on because
it's gonna lay eggs and [ __ ] and there's
another one out there there's a scene at
the airport and that was the scene Rose
like what
when you see Godzilla it's the execution
is what it is that's why would the fact
that you don't see the fight at the
airport is so irritating because the way
it's executed it looks like you're gonna
see the thing this monsters being a big
dick and also a huge kaboom you see the
foot could do it's Godzilla kun you see
him it pans up you're like oh it's Dino
Jesus and he looks cool it pans up you
see me does that roar he looks like
Godzilla I love the fact that he looks
like Godzilla there was a point in time
in cinema probably I was the 90s if we
remade something we felt like we had to
make it look different but we don't feel
like that anymore really yeah Godzilla's
it's he looked good for the time yet so
let's just make him look like Godzilla
it's good creature design back then it's
a good creature design now you don't
need to make Godzilla look like doomsday
with AIDS or anything like that you just
go ahead and make them look like
Godzilla that's what they did in this
movie with an intro like that we're
gonna see the fire we don't see the fire
you see the fight in the background
taking place on the news and [ __ ] you're
like I feel like I'm missing it the fact
that you see it in the background on
newscast it just it taunts you tangles
it in front of your face like a piece of
bait it's like nano uh throw away you
don't get that I get it they want to
draw it out they're drawing out the
anticipation you can't give people
dessert right out the gate doesn't
change the fact that everyone who saw
this movie even if you're this Godzilla
Pyrrhus who are like I'm actually
Godzilla didn't appear in the original
Godzilla until the last 15 minutes of
the movie they're just harkening back to
that even if you're that person you were
so like calf [ __ ] I wanted to see that
fight even when the dickbag EMP monster
gets to Vegas it's Vegas
everyone wants to see Vegas get
destroyed by a big monster and when that
happens you ultimately see the aftermath
it's like oh by the way that thing Tromp
through Vegas that sucks I wanted to see
this thing beaten buildings downs I
wanted to see him look at the Hilton be
like [ __ ] you and your night-vision porn
movie but the movie has a great tone to
it you know if things are creepy they're
creepy and eerie they're eerie and you
feel like civilizations coming to an end
in this movie that's the point of the
movie for sure skipping forward to the
end because that's what you want to hear
me talk about here godzilla confronts
the big beasts to fight him because used
to create equalizer he's like i need to
restore balance to the force and they
start fighting when they're scrapping
they're scrapping hard and like I said
Pacific Rim did it more extravagant mean
the Godzilla doesn't carry a big boat
like it's a baseball bat and crack
anyone over the head
but when they're throwing each other
into buildings and scrapping you're like
I feel like that's exactly how that
would look if this happened in my world
which creates an element of realism you
can't take for granted that's actually
really good
when I saw Godzilla's fins light up blue
is a Buddha I was like ah oh sure enough
he's a guy he shoots the fire and you're
like done getting pale is one of the
monsters it dies the other one how he
kills it I gotta be honest with you
of 2014 this is probably the best death
ever yet he grabs a thing by the mouth
we're talking is like straight ah he
just has it right there and he's all and
by spitting I mean he breathes fire down
the things neck is ah I just burns away
his neck and he's just holding the head
godzilla wins that is that doesn't
matter that he contributed to billions
of dollars of property damage this does
not matter anymore we erect a statue in
his honor because that death was awesome
yeah Godzilla shows up at the end of the
movie to kick ass and that was
disappointing for me it was
disappointing for some other people
purists out there like not to me because
that's how it is and that's where we're
all gonna different very point is
Godzilla's still a cool movie yeah
they're gonna make a sequel are you
kidding me there's something like
Godzilla makes money in the box-office
they make a sequel to it that's just
what's gonna happen so the question is
what are they gonna do in the sequel so
for a Godzilla sequel what do you think
is gonna happen in it what do you think
the monster is gonna be in the next one
whatever you think comment below let me
know as this does conclude my spoiler
video on Godzilla
I'm Jeremy Jones here remind you there
are two kinds of people in the world
people who pronounced his name Ken
Watanabe and people who pronounced his
name Ken wanton abhi those are the two
people and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you